Traductor: Javier Pardo
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Cuando vemos una película o una obra de teatro,
sabemos que los actores
probablemente aprendieron un guion,
que esencialmente les dice
qué decir
y cuándo decirlo.
Una pieza musical
funciona bajo el mismo principio.
De una manera bastante sencilla,
le dice al músico qué
y cuándo tocar.
Estéticamente hablando, existe una enorme diferencia
entre, digamos, Beethoven
y Justin Bieber,
pero ambos artistas usaron
los mismos ladrillos para crear su música:
las notas.
Y si bien el resultado final
puede sonar un poco complicado,
la lógica detrás de las notas musicales
es bastante sencilla.
Démosle un vistazo
a los elementos fundamentales de la notación musical
y veamos cómo interactúan para crear una obra de arte.
La música se escribe sobre cinco líneas paralelas
que atraviesan una hoja.
Estas cinco líneas se llaman pentagrama.
El pentagrama funciona en dos ejes:
el vertical
y el horizontal, de izquierda a derecha.
El eje vertical le indica al músico
el tono de la nota,
es decir, qué nota tocar,
y el eje horizonal le indica
el ritmo de la nota,
es decir, cuándo tocar.
Comencemos con el tono.
Para ayudarnos, vamos a usar un piano,
pero el sistema funciona prácticamente
con cualquier instrumento que puedas imaginarte.
En la tradición musical de Occidente,
los tonos llevan el nombre
de las 7 primeras letras del alfabeto,
A (LA),
B (SI),
C (DO),
D (RE),
E (MI),
F (FA),
y G (SOL),
Después, el ciclo se repite:
y así.
¿Pero de dónde obtienen los tonos sus nombres?
Bueno, por ejemplo, si tocaras un F (FA)
y luego tocaras otro F (FA)
más arriba o más abajo en el piano,
te darías cuenta que suenan bastante parecido
en comparación a, digamos, un B (SI).
Volviendo al pentagrama,
cada linea y cada espacio entre dos líneas
representa un tono por separado.
Si ponemos una nota en una de estas líneas
o uno de estos espacios,
le estamos diciendo al músico que toque ese tono.
Mientras más alta esté ubicada la nota en el pentagrama,
más alto será el tono.
Pero, obviamente, existen muchos, muchos más tonos
que los 9 que nos dan estas líneas y espacios.
En un piano de cola, por ejemplo, se pueden
tocar 88 notas distintas.
Entonces, ¿cómo metemos 88 notas en un solo pentagrama?
Usamos algo llamado clave.
Una clave es una figura extraña
que se ubica al principio del pentagrama
que actúa como punto de referencia
y que dice que una línea o espacio particular
corresponde a una nota específica en el instrumento.
Si queremos tocar las notas que no se encuentran en el pentagrama,
tenemos que hacer un poco de trampa y agregar pequeñas líneas
llamadas líneas auxiliares
y ubicar las notas sobre ellas.
Si necesitamos tantas demasiadas líneas auxiliares
que se torna confuso,
entonces necesitamos cambiar a otra clave.
En cuanto al cuándo tocar las notas,
existen dos elementos que controlan esto:
el tiempo
y el rítmo.
El tiempo de una obra es,
en sí, un poco aburrido.
Suena algo así.
Habrás notado que no cambia,
se mantiene de manera constante y acertada.
Puede ir despacio
o rápido
o como quieras, en serio.
El punto es que, como la manecilla de los segundos en un reloj
divide 1 minuto en 60 segundos,
con cada segundo tan largo como todos los otros,
el tiempo divide una pieza musical
en pequeños fragmentos de tiempo
que tienen todos la misma duración,
tiempos.
Con un tiempo constante como base,
podemos empezar a agregarle ritmo a nuestras notas,
y es ahí cuando la música realmente ocurre.
Esto es una negra.
La unidad más básica de ritmo,
y vale un tiempo.
Esto es una blanca, y vale dos tiempos.
Esto es una redonda y vale cuatro tiempos,
y estas pequeñitas se llaman corcheas,
y valen medio tiempo cada una.
—Genial, ¿pero qué significa eso? —dirás.
Te habrás dado cuenta
que a lo largo de un pentagrama,
existen pequeñas líneas que lo dividen en secciones más pequeñas.
Estos se llaman compases
y nos referimos a cada sección por compás.
Al comienzo de una pieza musical,
justo después de la clave,
existe algo llamado marca de tiempo,
la cual le indica al música cuántos tiempos hay en cada compás.
Este dice que hay dos tiempos en cada compás,
aquí dice que hay tres,
este cuatro,
y así.
El número de abajo nos dice qué tipo de nota
debe ser usada como unidad básica del tiempo.
El uno corresponde a una redonda,
el dos a una blanca,
el cuatro a una negra,
y el ocho a una corchea,
y así.
Por lo que esta marca de tiempo
nos dice que hay cuatro negras en cada compás,
uno,
dos,
tres,
cuatro;
uno,
dos,
tres,
cuatro,
y así.
Pero, como dije antes,
si solo nos atenemos al tiempo,
se torna un poco aburrido,
por lo que cambiaremos algunas negras
por otras figuras.
Habrás notado que si bien el número de notas
en cada compás ha cambiado,
no lo ha hecho el número total de tiempos en cada compás.
Entonces, ¿cómo suena nuestra creación musical?
Eh, suena bien, pero quizás un poco vacía, ¿no?
Agreguemos otro instrumento
con su propio tono y ritmo.
Ahora sí que suena como música.
Seguro, acostumbrarse a leer rápidamente
requiere un poco de práctica
así también como para tocar en nuestro instrumento lo que leemos
pero, con un poco de tiempo y paciencia,
podrías ser el próximo Beethoven
o
Justin Bieber.